la personne moyenne vit 27
375 jours c'est tout ce que nous obtenons si nous avons de la
chance nous voulons juste venir et dire
bonjour la première nuit où nous étions à
votre porte je suis généralement très spirituel et
charmant apportez-le bien
avez-vous ramassé  c'est mieux
complètement pire que
pourquoi pas c'est une idée horrible pour un rendez-vous oh
donc c'est un rendez-vous pas
emménager avec moi je vais te virer si
tu es nul pour vivre avec
jen ton homme je sais bien je servirais
ça dans  mon restaurant allez chop chop
chef d'accord
je ne savais pas combien je pouvais
vraiment aimer jusqu'à ce que je te rencontre
je n'ai jamais rien voulu de plus que
tu sois ma
femme c'est tout ce que je veux le jour de mon mariage
oh
si  on a de mauvaises nouvelles on devrait avoir un chien
ne dis pas qu'on a de bonnes nouvelles
ça fait beaucoup en ce
moment
nous savions que ça allait être dur je
suis avec toi je ne peux pas le faire  c'est à
toi que tu ne peux pas choisir quand je tape puis
-je choisir de ne plus être seul
[Musique]
merci de m'avoir montré ce qu'est la vie
quelle est la maison
tu me donnes l'impression que je peux faire tout ce
qu'il peut bien faire  tout ce qu'il y a 1 à 5
chances que je ne vois pas l'année prochaine 4-5
tu fais
tous les matins je me réveille et je te
choisis je nous choisis
toi